tear the mattwell show we've been told
for decades that there is nothing that
can be reasonably done to regulate
internet porn or protect kids from it
and yet starting this week the state of
Louisiana is doing the impossible and
porn apologists are not happy about it
also Kevin McCarthy encounters what the
media describes as historic opposition
to his bid to be speaker of the house
and our pro-lifer is really to blame for
the disappointing midterm results I'll
lay out why that's not the case UFC
president Dana White is caught on tape
in a slap fight with his wife but the
public reaction to the video is
incoherent and I'll explain why in our
daily cancellation of sports commentator
provokes an avalanche of national
outrage over his comments related to the
Demar Hamlin incident but was there
anything wrong with what he said or is
this yet another example of mindless
virtue signaling social media outrage
we'll talk about all that and more today
on the Matt Walsh show
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
now if you're someone who has always
wanted to read and understand the Bible
but you're not sure where to start then
check out the Bible in a year podcast
from Ascension the Bible into your
podcast is currently the most popular
religion podcast in the US millions of
people have listened to it and twice
it's hit the number one spot on Apple
podcast in the Bible in a year father
Mike Schmitz reads the entire Bible in
365 daily episodes providing helpful
commentary reflection and prayer along
the way what better way is there to
start the new year you can find the
Bible in a year podcast with father Mike
Schmitz for free in your favorite
podcast app or on YouTube plus you can
follow along with a special reading plan
to help you better understand the story
unlike any other Bible podcast Bible and
ear follows a special reading plan that
organizes the books of the Bible in a
way that helps listeners understand the
story you can get this reading plan at
ascensionpress.com Welsh if you want to
start reading and more importantly
understanding the Bible this year go to
ascensionpress.com Walsh to download the
reading plan for free that's
ascensionpress.com Walsh to download the
reading plan for free
over the years including recently just a
couple of weeks ago when I have
discussed the need for at a minimum some
basic regulations on the internet porn
industry that would provide at least
minimal protection to children I have
been met with a number of objections and
all of them are incredibly lame and
unconvincing but the principal objection
has always been that such regulations
are somehow infeasible if not impossible
laws and regulations in every state
require every other adult oriented
industry to verify ages whether online
or in real life but for whatever reason
we could never expect porn companies to
abide by these same rules every other
company uh can but but not porn
companies now granted we've never tried
there's never been any serious attempt
at any level to even moderately regulate
internet porn but we've decided that it
can't be done anyway there's no sense in
even trying so let's just keep feeding
generation after generation of children
into this wood chipper allowing their
minds and souls to be corrupted by the
most depraved forms of Filth ever
conceived while we sit by helplessly on
the assumption that even if we tried to
do something we couldn't do anything and
so we'll just do nothing
yet now into this picture steps the
state of Louisiana which as of this week
has set out to do and is in fact now
doing the impossible they have not only
done it but they've done it relatively
quickly and cheaply and easily
they haven't entirely solved the problem
of children accessing hardcore porn and
there are plenty of loopholes still to
be closed but in the span of a couple of
days they have made more progress than
had been made collectively for the whole
history of internet porn up until now
all it took was the willingness to do it
that is the only thing that has held us
back from protecting our kids from these
filthy smut Peddlers we have been
unwilling to even try
but in Louisiana they are now trying
they're putting a law in place that uh
that that requires foreign sites to
verify ages to actually verify the age
of every user who uh tries to access the
site so here's advice on the Louisiana
law they write quote a new law makes
porn sites liable for Content deemed
harmful to minors if it doesn't install
age verification technology for anyone
accessing them in Louisiana and it's
already affecting how people in the
state access PornHub the law which was
signed by Louisiana's Democratic
governor John Bel Edwards in June became
effective on January 1st 2023. now make
special note of the fact that a Democrat
Governor signed this bill and I know
it's Louisiana but this is a Democrat
Governor signing this bill so if your
state is run by a republican Governor
you should be asking why he or she has
not signed a similar Bill if the
Democrats are doing it
Vice continues the law passed as act
440 States quote any commercial entity
that knowingly and intentionally
publishes or distributes material
harmful to minors on the internet from a
website that contains a substantial
portion of such material shall be held
liable if the entity fails to perform
reasonable age verification methods to
verify the age of individuals attempting
to access the material it also states
that any commercial entity in violation
will be liable to an individual for
damages resulting from a Miner's access
to the material motherboard confirmed
through a virtual private Network that
PornHub is showing people visiting the
site the site from a louisiana-based IP
address a page that requires identity
verification before entering
uh the page says Louisiana law now
requires us to put in place a process
for verifying the age of users who
connect to our site for from Louisiana
the P the page says when motherboard
tested the verification PornHub directed
us to all past trust which is a third
party identity verification site which
connects to La wallet which is a digital
driver's license for louisianans PornHub
guarantees that PornHub doesn't connect
collect data during this process
now the article goes on to note that
some other major porn sites haven't yet
put anything into place to comply with
the new law only fans meanwhile can't be
accessed at all right now from a
Louisiana IP address perhaps they've
shut down access until they can get
something in place to verify ages
perhaps they'll never restore accents at
all which would be the best case
scenario really
but the fact remains that the biggest
porn distributor in the world has
figured out a way to conform itself
to these sort of basic regulation that
once again literally every other adult
oriented business is required to comply
with
an exception has been carved out for
internet porn a totally baseless
indefensible exception
and in Louisiana at least that exception
that loophole has been closed
now one of the most important parts of
closing the loophole is the financial
liability as mentioned in the article
porn sites now have a major incentive to
try and keep kids off of their platforms
whereas up until now
they have had no incentive to keep kids
off indeed the incentives have gone the
other way
like we have been actively incentivizing
porn sites to expose kids to their
uh to to this stuff lowering kids onto
the platforms early and often up until
now in Louisiana anyway guaranteed
millions of new porn addicts every year
translating into billions and billions
of dollars
that that was the incentive the only way
to compete with this kind of profit
motive is to as Louisiana has done make
porn sites financially liable for the
harm caused to the children exposed to
their product
this yet again is exactly what we do
with every other industry that sells a
product that is potentially harmful to
kids
we require them to put measures into
place to ensure that kids are not
accessing the product if they fail to
enact such measures and their
recklessness results in children gaining
access to their product or service they
are subject to fines and lawsuits
there is no reason why porn companies
should continue to enjoy the
unprecedented privilege of being able to
harm whoever they want and profit from
it without a shred of accountability
so why shouldn't similar measures be put
in place in every state
and on the federal level too
you know the harm that pornography
consumption afflicts on the developing
minds of children is is not a subject Up
For Debate any longer
there is no debate about it there is no
question that a young child who is
exposed to hardcore porn suffers very
real emotional and psychological trauma
which manifests itself immediately and
in in in the long term in Myriad ways
none of them good
this is not only proven by the research
but it is an inescapable conclusion
reached by anyone with the slightest bit
of Common Sense
because we know that the human mind is
impressionable and the mind of a child
is more impressionable still marketing
departments know this advertising the
advertising industry knows this
so what kind of lasting impression then
is left on a child who's introduced
introduced to the concept of human
sexuality through exposure to forms of
sexual debauchery and depravity that
human beings prior to the internet age
could not have even conceived of
okay this is stuff that that most people
have ever lived on earth prior to the
internet never would have seen or even
thought of
and now we have eight-year-olds who are
ingesting it every day
what impression what impact does that
have on the child
you don't need to put on a lab coat and
conduct a scientific study to answer
that question but as it happens people
have conducted such studies and the
results line up with what common sense
already attests to
so back to the question
what is the argument against this
what is the problem with taking even the
most meager and basic steps to prevent
internet pimps from Hawking their
poisonous product to seven-year-olds
why isn't this happening everywhere why
is it only Just Happening Now in one
state
well there really is no argument against
it I mean I know that because I've asked
the critics you know those freaking out
about this Louisiana law and similar
efforts efforts elsewhere uh I've asked
people to explain it to me for years
I've been asking this question
and they can't explain it the most they
can do is mutter about how protecting
children from porn is the parent's job
which it is yes but it's also the
government's job to protect its citizens
and that includes indeed ought to
especially include children
see children should be at the front of
the line when it comes to protection
from the government
you expect to be protected from the
government adults expect it
you expect various forms of protection
well children should be in the front of
their mind they should be in front of
all of us when it comes to being
protected
and parents cannot contend with a porn
saturated culture all on their own
they cannot be left alone to deal with
this that is not a fair thing to expect
and there's no reason why they should be
now we're also told that this is a
slippery slope
uh there was a viral tweet from someone
who's identifies themselves as a a um
uh criminal defense attorney in
Louisiana Anonymous and also
anti-fascist he says and he was his
viral tweet and he lives in Louisiana
he's very he's very upset that now he's
uh you know he has to go through one
extra step before accessing PornHub so
his masturbation has to he has to hold
off on that for another like 30 seconds
very upset about that and so he's
tweeted this long viral thread say this
is a slippery slope into fascism a
surveillance state
you know first the government will
require identification for accessing
PornHub and then next some bad thing
will happen
you know of all the weak half cocked
faux libertarian arguments that porn
apologists come up with this is probably
the dumbest of all and that's saying a
lot
and I'll just respond to it this way I I
need everyone to pay attention to this
part because it's very important
the government does not need the
precedent of a good thing
in order to do a bad thing
okay they'll just do the bad thing
so whatever you're worried about well so
maybe maybe protecting kids from porn is
okay but then that would lead to the
government doing this other thing
whatever that other thing is they're
already doing it it is already doing
whatever bad thing you're worried about
the question is simply whether amid all
the bad the government does it ought to
at least also do a good thing or two
another way of putting this
because the government does a lot of
things that aren't it's lawful or
rightful job
should we then object on the rare
occasion when it actually does it's a
lawful and rightful job
protecting children from multi-billion
Dollar porn Merchants is fully and
clearly within the purview of the
government
why in God's name would you oppose that
based on the fact that it's also doing a
bunch of things that are not in its
purview
yeah it shouldn't be doing that but the
stuff in its purview it should be doing
I mean talk about throwing the baby out
with the bathwater
except in this case you're just throwing
the baby out and keeping the dirty bath
water it's the worst of all worlds
but it's no surprise that such bad
arguments would be made by those opposed
to protecting kids from porn they can't
be blamed for their bad arguments they
are trying to defend the indefensible
and they're doing it for reasons that
they won't really say out loud
that's why all the arguments are so
stupid and bad is because because none
of these people will actually say what
their real argument is their real
motivation is to as we talked about a
couple weeks ago not only protect their
own ease of access to pornography but
also I think
at a deeper level
they want to avoid thinking about the
harm that pornography inflicts on people
to begin with you know this entire
conversation requires us to confront
what pornography is and how toxic it is
and and uh and that causes the adult
porn user to feel bad about himself and
his habits
I think it's that's really why he'd
prefer that we not talk about it or do
anything about it
but that's also yet another reason why
we must
now let's get to our headlines
it's extremely important to protect your
online privacy with a VPN choosing a VPN
you trust is equally as important and
then I can say with full confidence that
expressvpn is the best VPN on the market
here's why first expressvpn doesn't log
your online activity other cheap or free
vpns make money by selling your data to
advertisers but not expressvpn they even
developed a technology that makes it
impossible for their servers to store
any data at all
second expressvpn has engineered a new
VPN protocol that makes user speeds
faster than ever you can even stream HD
videos with zero buffering and lastly
expressvpn is incredibly easy to use you
just heard me talk about a lot of
technical features but you don't need
any technical skills to get started with
it fortunately if you did I wouldn't be
able to use it just fire up the app and
tap one button and you're connected and
that's it so it's not just me saying
this Business Insider The Verge many
other Tech journals rate expressvpn the
number one VPN in the world so protect
yourself with the VPN that I trust use
mylake expressvpn.com Walsh today and
get three months free on a one-year
package that's exp
resvpn.com Walsh expressvpn.com Welsh
all right if you're watching on the
video podcast I don't want you to get
overwhelmed by the fancy new camera
angles we're doing we're going full
Hollywood on you now we've got camera
angles I'm moving around the table
and that's uh mostly just so I get it's
the only bit of cardio I get in my life
anymore it's just is just sliding around
this little circular table so it'll
Stave off uh obesity for another 30
minutes anyway so Washington Post
headline here uh Kevin McCarthy faces
open GOP revolta's house fails to elect
speaker Republican leader Kevin McCarthy
faced open Revolt in the house chamber
Tuesday failing in three rounds of
balloting to earn enough votes to
capture the speakership in a once in a
century Showdown that will now spill
into a second day the stunning failure
of the house to elect a speaker on its
first round of voting came after uh
McCarthy and his allies spent weeks
working to secure the 218 votes needed
for him to take the gavel Republicans
won back the house in November's
midterms but worth a slim four vote
majority requiring near consensus among
the conference to vote uh move votes
forward by early Tuesday it became clear
that hard right GOP holdouts had not
been swayed the failure was the
culmination of internal divide that had
in the past helped to bring down the
speakerships of John Boehner and Paul
Ryan
with members of the staunchly
conservative House Freedom caucus asking
for a range of demands in exchange for
their votes so this is another example
of a couple things about this um
another example of the kind of story the
media makes a big deal uh about and
political pundits make a big deal about
it you know we hear historic Showdown
once in a century not this is we've ever
we haven't seen this In Our Lifetime and
uh but most people I suspect
aren't even aware this is happening
couldn't care less who the speaker of
the house is and and in reality
it probably doesn't matter all that much
to your life like it it probably whether
Kevin McCarthy is the speaker of the
house or some other Republican or if
they put a a broken toaster oven as a
Speaker of the House of those three
options it would your life would
probably be exactly the same like if I
were to give you
three
um crystal balls that I didn't tell you
which was which and and they give you a
vision of your future
in each scenario here's the crystal ball
where Kevin McCarthy speaker house
here's another Republican here's the
broker toaster broken toaster oven you
know scenario and you were to look into
it and see what your life is like you
wouldn't be able to tell which because
it would be exactly the same is what I'm
trying to say your life would play out
exactly the same no matter who speaker
the house is
with that being said
um
Kevin McCarthy for what it's worth
doesn't deserve the speakership and uh
this is not we could call it a historic
Showdown with these so-called hard right
Republicans are refusing to go along
refuse and go along with it just means
that they don't think that
um Kevin McCarthy
is these other house members they don't
want to vote for a leader who they
rightly have judged to be unfit and to
be a failure
Kevin McCarthy in his role in Republican
leadership has been a failure
and it's not just because of the
disappointing to put a mildly midterm
results
but that's just the latest in a line of
failures what is it what is this another
way of looking at is like what has this
guy achieved exactly nothing
he's just another Republican
establishment kind of squishy nobody
empty suit kind of guy
and this idea that he that he deserves
the speakership that it belongs to him
that he should have it that is the most
establishment-like mentality of all
that is establishment too that's what
the establishment is it's this idea that
certain people deserve these roles in
government
and so everyone else would just step
aside
but that's not the way it's supposed to
work
and I say that about the speaker of the
house I say that about the presidency
you know you hear from some people who
are Trump uh fans that well no this is
it's his turn again in 2024 everyone
else should step aside it doesn't it's
not turn what it means your turn it's
nobody's turn
if you want a role in government as an
elected official you got to run for it
and earn it get the votes
and if you want to be speaker of the
house you have to get the votes from
your members
and he doesn't have them right now and
he shouldn't
because again he's a failure he's a
nobody and really the onus is on him so
all the people that are worried about uh
well this is a this is a historic
meltdown and it's it's it's making the
Republicans look stupid or whatever you
hear this a lot it's a big clown show
again most people aren't paying
attention so most people don't care
and as far as Republicans making
themselves look stupid uh they don't
need any help with that Republicans make
themselves look stupid every day but not
because of this
this is one example of Republicans some
Republicans at least actually standing
on principle
and standing up against their own
so-called leadership and having a
backbone having a spine
this this is an example of them making a
republican no this is this is like the
one time when they don't look stupid
but even if that's true
then then whose fault is it you know
then the onus is on Kevin McCarthy to
step down step aside
you don't have the votes
if you're worried about how this all
looks and that it's some sort of uh
historic Quagmire
then why aren't you putting the pressure
on Kevin McCarthy to step aside and
clear the way for someone else
he's failed in his role of leadership he
doesn't have the confidence of many of
uh of the members and so he should step
aside
I see the onus on him
that's where it should be
all right Fox news headline DeSantis
calls Florida land of sanity and slams
Biden policies in his inaugural address
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis on Tuesday
praise the Sunshine State as the land of
liberty and land of Sanity while
slamming the floundering Federal
establishment in Washington DC the bite
Administration and laying out his
policies for the months and years ahead
as he was sworn in for a second term the
santis uh who's considered a likely GOP
2024 presidential Contender delivered
his inaugural address on the steps of
the state's capital in Tallahassee on
Tuesday after a decisive 19-point
re-election Victory now it was a great
speech and all and I think it's uh
it's worth a very good speech at least
worth watching but this was the best
part here's just a 20 second clip
and this may not seem very remarkable to
you what he says here but this to me was
my favorite part of his speech listen to
this
Florida must always be a great place to
raise a family we will enact more
family-friendly policies to make it
easier to raise children and we will
defend our children against those who
seek to Rob them of their innocence
there you go very simple like I said
doesn't appear to be anything
revolutionary there
um and there isn't
but this should be the Republican
party's platform going into 2024.
and this is if you want to know what my
political ideology is at this point
that's it well you just heard there
that's that's the whole thing
protect families protect children
there you go
uh that's what that's it that's the
fundamental political platform and
that's what every Republican ought to be
talking about
and if the term conservatism means
anything it ought to be conserving that
I mean most fundamentally as I always
talk about it's conserving basic truth
it's also conserving and protecting the
family and uh and you know and this the
safety and innocence of children
that should be
the marching Waters
and not only is that the right
you know the right platform and the
right mission
and and what needs to be done
but it's also a winning political
message
forget about what you've heard from
squishy establishment Republicans for
years and years
still to this day
you know they will go down with the ship
claiming that all anybody cares about is
their wallet and the financial bottom
line and so just talk about tax cuts and
all of that that's all anything anybody
cares about
that's not true people care about money
they care about their financial
well-being of course they do we all do
but they care about those things
primarily because of how that affects
the the uh safety and stability of their
families and their children
because even more basic than the
financial concern is that concern about
your family about your kids this is what
people
this is why I always say you know you
gotta you gotta think about what do
people wake up in the morning thinking
about
okay they don't wake up in the morning
thinking about tax cuts nobody does
um if you're a parent you wake up in the
morning and you're thinking about your
kids you're thinking about your family
you're thinking about your spouse like
that's that's the first thoughts in your
mind
and politically if you're speaking to
that if you're speaking to forget about
the kitchen table issues I'm talking
about before you even get to the kitchen
table okay before you sit down the
kitchen table for breakfast what are the
things that you're thinking about
and it's that
and politically if you're speaking to
those issues
um then that's that is going to be a
winner every time for almost everybody
all right
here's something else uh this is if I
pull it up here
as far a story from last week that I I
wanted to touch on that the hill
headline says Trump says abortion issue
responsible for GOP underperforming
expectations in the midterms is the
article from last week former president
Trump blamed the abortion issue quote
unquote for Republicans underperforming
expectations of the 2022 midterm
elections Trump said in a post on true
social on Sunday that many of the GOP
handled the issue poorly especially
those who firmly insisted on no
exceptions to bans on the procedure
including on instances of rape and
incest
um well rather than reading the article
I'll just read you what he what he uh
posted on Truth social he says it wasn't
my fault that the Republicans didn't
live up to expectations in the midterms
I was 233 to 20. it was the uh it was
the abortion issue poorly handled by
many Republicans especially those that
firmly insisted on no exceptions even in
the cases of rape incestor life of the
mother that lost large numbers of Voters
also the people that pushed so hard for
decades against abortion got their wish
from the U.S Supreme Court and just
plain disappeared not to be seen again
plus Mitch stupid money
stupid money
I'm not even sure that means Mitch Mitch
stupid and then a dollar sign apostrophe
s anyway
so that's what he said now
there are a few problems here
the first is that before you even get to
the substance
this is just whiny you know like I I
think one rule in politics and also to
be an adult in life is like
never start a sentence with it wasn't my
fault that
never start a sentence that way
um even if you're trying to deny Fault
in in a situation don't start us it
sounds whiny it just sounds weak and
whiny that's how it sounds
and it again makes you think like
because this is this what the Trump
campaign is he announced his candidacy
what two months ago now
and then and then disappeared like where
is he and and it dis announces candidacy
and rather than launching right into
rallies and exciting things and making
announcements and you know stirring
things up he just like retreats to
Mar-A-Lago and is issuing these uh
these what do they call them truths on
Truth social deflecting blame looking
backwards all this kind of it looks weak
and whiny and irrelevant that's the
first problem
the second is putting blame at the feet
of pro-lifers which by the way is what
the Republican establishment speaking of
them it's what they've always done
okay this what you hear here which what
you hear in this case
is a
slightly more direct
version of what the Republican
establishment has been saying for
decades anytime there's a major
political defeat they always and I know
this as a pro-lifer myself and someone
who's been in the movement for years uh
standing in the group
that that always has the fingers
pointing at it from the Conservative
Republican establishment that's all
their fault
because they care too much about
protecting babies from being murdered
um
it doesn't make any sense it's not true
especially from the guy who in the past
has bragged about the Dobbs decision
this the the Dobb's decision is
legitimately a legacy of the Trump
Administration
if we didn't have Trump if Hillary
Clinton had won in 2016 then obviously
she would not have appointed uh three
justices who would then go on to
overturn Roe v Wade
so this is
not only part of his legacy but it is
the most important part and and also
perhaps the only lasting bit of Legacy
that there is everything else that Trump
did was was was undone by Joe Biden in
about five seconds
this is the one lasting thing and it's
one of the most important moments in
American history is the overturning of
Roe v Wade
even with the states that still have uh
you know still kill babies
even with them it's still tens of
thousands at least of lives saved every
year because of this at least
so that's something that Trump should be
championing and he has in the past until
now he's turning around pointing the
fingers at pro-lifers
and and it is pro-lifers by the way it's
not just it's not just singling out
certain Republican politicians
saying Republicans generally voters
who are too firm in insisting on no
exceptions for uh rape and incest and
life of the mother and all the rest of
it
you know why we don't
agree with those exceptions
because the exceptions are morally
incoherent it doesn't make any sense
okay
there is only one reason to oppose any
abortion at all okay there's only one
reason I don't care the circumstances
that lead that led up to the baby being
conceived uh what what stage of
pregnancy we're talking about the manner
of the abortion putting all that
whatever that doesn't matter whatever
kind of abortion we're talking about
there's only one reason to oppose it
and that one single reason is that the
child is a human child
and that intentionally killing a human
child is murder it is the murder of a
child that is the one single reason to
oppose abortion and it's a really good
reason
you know when you have a good reason we
have a good argument you don't need any
other arguments
when you've got a trump card argument
that's all you need
and that's our one single trump card
argument
this is a human child scientifically
you are intentionally killing it and
that by definition is murder
intentionally killing human life is
better this is the murder of a child
that we are opposed to murdering
children
the only reason to be post-abortion
but if you oppose abortion for that
reason
it doesn't make any sense to carve out
exceptions
how can you possibly say well I oppose
murdering children except for
what except for
there are some things where there can be
no except for there could be no but
and this is one of them
if abortion is murdering a child
then there can never be a situation
where it is okay to do because there is
never a situation where it is okay to
murder a child
but if abortion is not the murder of a
child then there's never any reason to
oppose it
then you're not murdering a child you're
just dispensing of inanimate meaningless
matter and why shouldn't you do that
those are the two options
okay that's not me being extreme or hard
blind or anything I mean you could call
it that if you want I don't care
it's really just about being morally and
intellectually consistent
and if you're if your argument on this
topic is not morally intellectually
consistent then it just falls apart
okay this is not about a purity test or
something like that
standing on pedestals I'm more principle
than the rest of you that's not what
this is
it's just your argument falls apart if
it's incoherent which the exception
thing is incoherent so just that's
that's that form of being pro-life
doesn't work it doesn't achieve anything
it doesn't win the argument because it
can't
yeah now Pro the so-called moderate
pro-lifers they benefit from the fact
that pro-abortion people are very bad at
arguing their case
but if they were any good at it then
they could easily you know like how
would an argument how would a con
imagine how a conversation with a
competent pro-abortion person would go
argument between a competent
pro-abortion person if they exist and a
so-called moderate pro-lifer who
believes in exceptions
so the moderate pro-lifer says abortion
is the murder of a baby we shouldn't be
allowed to do it
competent pro-abortion person says well
what about rape and incest
life of the mother
oh yeah well no except for those that's
okay
so in those cases it's okay to murder a
child
so those children can be murdered you're
saying
well I I mean uh yes
the moment they get you to admit that
you're actually saying it can be okay
sometimes to murder a child
you lost
all right uh Joy read this week has
joined in the pro-lifer pile on uh I
want you to listen to this 90-second
clip because there's a lot to be learned
about leftist misinformation strategies
here listen to this as we brace for a
republican-controlled house at a post
row America it may be a good time to
take a closer look at just what the
so-called pro-life party has been doing
or attempting to do legislatively since
winning their tiny majority in November
over the past month Congress has voted
on numerous pieces of legislation and
while several passed with bipartisan
support there was a considerable amount
of Republican opposition to members that
all had one thing in common that is they
affect either pregnant people mothers or
young children
and these weren't complicated Authority
issues in fact they all seemed like
pretty basic bare minimum stuff for
example in the house 90 Republicans
voted against the pregnant women in
custody act which would guarantee
minimum levels of Health Care and
nutrition for women who are pregnant and
incarcerated in their newborns while
also preventing those who were eight
months pregnant from being placed in
solitary confinement among the
politicians who voted against the bill
were Matt Gates and soon to be
ex-congressman Madison cawthorne 44
Republicans voted against a bill that
aims to provide maternity services for
pregnant and postpartum veterans Yes you
heard that right the part of it
supposedly loves the military doesn't
want to help those serving our country
while pregnant make it make sense 17
Republicans voted against the early
hearing detection and intervention act a
bill that would help early diagnosis and
treatment for deaf and hard of hearing
newborns because apparently they only
care about the health of babies who are
in utero once you're out you're on your
own kid
now I continue to be just amazed that
anyone watches that show on purpose even
if you agree with what she's saying how
can you she it's just grading to listen
to
um now the claim that she makes there at
the end that this is one of the the
ultimate uh political cliches that
conservatives only care about life in
the womb
talk about being incoherent
um that doesn't like that just goes to
show
that what left us have in their head
they haven't they had this cart you know
this cartoonish idea of conservatives
and they really believe it they see
their opposition as a cartoon
which makes them vulnerable makes them
easier to beat
because you can't it's you can't defeat
an enemy if you don't understand them
you have to understand them first
but leftists don't understand
conservatives and they don't want to try
to understand because they're trying to
understand conservatives means taking us
seriously for at least a moment or two
so you can try to understand where we're
coming from and then you can you can
formulate strategies and arguments
against us but they won't do that
so they have this cartoonish idea of uh
like Psychopaths who who who care deeply
about children in the womb but the
moment the moment they're born they
don't
just psychologically that doesn't make
any sense
the the whole argument right
for uh caring about
life in the womb
is by drawing a comparison to life
outside of the womb and making the
observation that there is no substantive
distinction between life in the womb and
life outside the womb
so our whole argument hinges on the fact
that life outside of the womb has
meaning and value
if we didn't believe that then there'd
be no reason to think that life inside
the womb has meaning and value
and The Morbid irony here is of course
on the left they're the ones who
actually don't think that life outside
of the womb has any value they don't
think the life inside the womb has value
and they also don't think about life
outside these two these two things go
hand in hand because it's the same life
we're talking about
and so if a baby five seconds before
emerging from the birth canal has no
value according to you
it is guaranteed you're also not going
to see much value in it a second after
it emerges from the birth canal because
nothing has changed
it is just it has switched locations in
space that's it
whereas if you really believe that that
baby has value a second before emerging
for the birth now of course you'll still
think that when the child emerges
because again nothing has changed
so on the left they're the ones of the
nihilists who don't believe that uh
life has any intrinsic value but just to
show you how you can't trust anything
these people say let's take one of the
claims that she made
she said that all these Republicans
voted against the pregnant women in
custody Act
which she says was supposed to guarantee
proper treatment of pregnant women in
custody
so why would Republicans vote against
that
well there was one Republican
representative Scott Fitzgerald who's
quoted in a media article explaining the
issue with this law
and he says
um
we all believe that pregnant
incarcerated women should be well cared
for while they're in federal custody
however I would like to note the concern
the bill would require the Bureau of
Prisons to provide a board of patience
to pregnant inmates however the word
contraception is not defined in the bill
and the internal Bureau of Prisons
policy does not define contraception
because of the word contraception is not
defined this ambiguity leaves the
reasonable interpretation of the term
contraception and could include
abortifacions or other substances that
induce abortion
okay so this
uh this bill wasn't simply about
protecting pregnant women in custody
which by the way women what are those
okay uh is this like one of the only
times a little knowledge that women even
exist but this was not about protecting
pregnant women in custody what the bill
says here's the language of the bill
access to complete appropriate Health
Services for the life cycle of women the
director of the Bureau of Prison shall
ensure that each woman of reproductive
age is in custody at a bureau of prison
facility a has access to contraception
and testing for pregnancy and sexually
transmitted diseases upon request of any
such woman and B is administered a
pregnancy test on the date on which the
woman enters a facility which the woman
May decline
okay
so this isn't exclusively for pregnant
women
it's actually also for non-pregnant
women any woman of reproductive age as
it says
guaranteeing birth control
well all you do is think about that for
a second why would you need birth
control in prison
but what's the need for that
now of course I say that but as they
introduce males into women's prisons uh
the the you know the the possibility and
the actuality of women getting pregnant
while in the lockup is that is happening
more and more
but on a normal circumstances
um you wouldn't think there'd be much
need for birth control in a prison in a
women's prison
which just leads all the more to the
suspicion that when you say
contraception you're also including
abortivations
and that was not properly defined in the
bill there was nothing put in there that
that's that's that stipulates no we're
not going to be requiring taxpayers to
give aboard patients to pregnant inmates
and all the rest of it and because of
that there were some Republicans who
rightly voted against it of course we
don't hear that from Joy Reid
all right
one other quick thing Yahoo sports
UFC president Dana White admits to
slapping his wife on New Year's Eve now
this is a story that's gotten a lot of
attention uh Dana White slaps his wife
beat his wife as some on social media
have put it
lots of outrage about this lots of
claims that white is a domestic abuser
lots of condemnation Etc uh before we
talk about it let's check the video here
it is
[Music]
okay
so there it is
um so his wife slaps him he slaps her
back and all the headlines saying Dana
White slapped his wife could just as
well say Dana White's wife slaps Dana
White but we know why they don't here's
what I'll say about this you know the
position
most people especially on the left
have on this condemning Dana White and
this maybe is the theme we're talking
about today people have incoherent
positions well the position of most of
these people again particularly on the
left
it's an incoherent position
um because if you truly believe that men
and women are entirely equal there's no
difference between the two in fact the
categories don't even exist according to
you they don't even think these words
don't even mean anything if that's what
you believe which every person on the
left just about pretends to believe
then
there just is no basis for condemning
for for any like serious condemnation of
Dana White because then you have one
individual who was slapped by another
individual and that individual slapped
back so yeah you could blame them and
say you'd be the bigger man uh you know
be more mature or whatever but
it it's to go beyond that just doesn't
make any sense
so if you're consistent in that belief
then you should look at that video and
react to it the exact same way that you
would react to a different video of a of
a man let's say a smaller man walks up
to Dana White slaps him in the face and
then Dana White slaps that man back
if you believe that men and women are
entirely equal
um then you should react to the one of
him and his wife the same way you'd
react to that and how would you react
how would anyone react to a video of a
smaller man walking up to Dana White
slapping him in the face getting slapped
back almost every single now there might
be a few people who say uh you know be
more mature
but almost every person would respond by
saying well don't go up and slap Dana
White I mean you got slapped back
because you slapped him if he's a bigger
guy you shouldn't be doing that
fafo right F around and find out that's
what everybody would be that's what
every single person would be saying now
we all know that
so to Heap any sort of extra
condemnation on Dana White that the only
way to do that
the only way to condemn him Beyond how
you would condemn him
if he slapped another man who slapped
him first which is you wouldn't condemn
him hardly at all in that case the only
way to do it is on the grounds of
chivalry
it's on the grounds of like a
recognition
that men and women are not equal
and that there are codes of chivalry and
conduct
um that men should abide by
but men should men should treat women
differently from how they treat men
for and and women should treat men
differently from how they treat other
women
that is the only basis upon which
you can coherently condemn Dana White
here
but most people doing the condemnation
they don't accept that basis and so it's
all it's all incoherent
which by the way you know and I'm a
Believer in chivalry
um
but does chivalry lead to the conclusion
that it's never acceptable under any
circumstance for a man to strike well of
course not I mean there there could
certainly be and have been conceivable
scenarios where uh self-defense is
necessary like you're not you're not
called upon as a man to just be beaten
silly uh and to not defend yourself at
all because the person doing it as a
woman that's absurd
but generally it's kind of a general
principle
if you don't subscribe to the leftist
notion that the Sexes are equal then you
see that they're unequal and uh you
think well men should respond in
situations differently to women and then
they respond to men
all right let's get to the comment
section
[Music]
[Applause]
it's a sweet baby gang
the beginning of a new year sets the
tone for the rest of it if one of your
goals is to take control of your credit
card debt which is a great goal to have
then you need to check out lightstream a
credit card consolidation from
lightstream can help you pay off your
credit cards and lock in a low fixed
interest rate rates start at 7.99 APR
with auto pay and excellent credit plus
the rate is fixed so it will never
increase over the life of your loan you
can get a loan from five thousand to a
hundred thousand dollars without any
fees at all you can even get your money
as soon as the day you apply lightstream
believes that people with good credit to
serve a better loan experience and
that's exactly what they deliver just
from our listeners apply now to get a
special interest rate discount and save
even more the only way to get this
discount is to go to lightstream.com
Walsh Lig
h-t-s-t-r-e-a-m.com Walsh subject to
credit approval Rate rates range from
7.99 APR to 23.99 APR and include 0.5
percent auto pay discount lowest rate
requires excellent credit terms and
conditions apply and offers are subject
to change without notice visit
lightstream.com walls for more
information
says there was once a frog and a beaker
full of water the beaker was over a
Bunsen burner and the water in the
beaker was slowly getting hotter at some
point the Frog began to realize that he
was in danger and in a panic began to
try to get out of the water fortunately
someone convinced the frog that he was
only having a moral panic and he was
able to die in peace
perfect
you have uh Michael I will say you have
in a YouTube comment you have succinctly
summarized our cultural condition there
you have uh that that's pretty much it
that's the whole story that's the whole
story of a modern mushroom culture
a body in progress says Matt managed to
say senior member of research at Media
Matters without laughing out loud at the
idea that Media Matters does research
and has a senior member of that
department that takes major acting
skills it's not acting at all I mean
it's they they uh
it's it's it's research I mean it's very
tough research too because they have to
watch me every day and that's uh it's
not I know it's not difficult not an
easy thing to do
so as always I thank them for their
service
Janet says my heart swells with pride
for you Dad
dad well Sweet Daddy Walsh is the of
course the the proper name and if your
heart is swelling you probably shouldn't
have gotten that booster shot
raptorman 101 says the 2 million
subscriber special should be Matt
confronting people who haven't returned
their shopping carts
you know well we've already we've
already we've run past two million
subscribers without even noting it I
guess this is like once well I guess
that's this thing once you get the first
you can get to the first million it's a
big deal
and then uh and then after that it's
like nobody cares anyway I think you
have to get to 100 the next one that
anyone would care about is if I get to
100 million subscribers
um
similar to what and I will abide by that
because this is what I say all the time
about about uh about birthdays you know
we celebrate birthdays when you're a
child and in YouTube terms sort of like
your childhood and Adolescence is before
you get to the million subscribers and
then you get there you're an adult now
YouTuber and uh and we don't really
recognize birthdays until it's something
really significant
uh as far as confronting people who
haven't returned their shopping carts I
would love to do that but that is
already that service is already being
provided by uh by carton arcs and
they're out there every day
um hunting down people who aren't
returning the shopping carts and I think
they're doing a fantastic job I would
want to steal I wouldn't want to steal
the idea from them
but also I think
they're already performing that service
let's see
Andrew says Matt do you actually have to
watch a WNBA game or can you hang out at
the concession stands and walk around
the arena when you're at the WNBA game
through WWE NBA games even have
concession stands I don't mean that as a
joke do they actually sell
is there someone there who tries to
actually sell like merchandise and and
food
um
is it just some kid with a lemonade
stand selling lemonade for uh in a
plastic cup for 25 cents well whatever
it is no I think
it's it this is clear you know I gotta I
have to sit and actually watch
the game and as I've been saying all
along I I
nobody's ever watched entire WNBA game
before so we don't
In fairness we're all sort of assuming
that it will be
horribly boring and tedious we're
assuming that
and I think it's a pretty safe
assumption but no one's tested the
theory no one's actually tested the
theory not one single person this is a
scientific fact not one single person in
the world has ever actually watched an
entire wib again NBA game and and I and
so I am going to be that first person
and we'll find out maybe I'll
enjoy it maybe I'll get into it
uh maybe I'll be their first fan
that would be a twist ending that nobody
would see coming
and finally Tampa Tampa six says my
response to Matt's assault on Ranch is
simple we agree on a lot roughly 99 but
I will hold my ground
if you want me to stop covering my
pineapple pizza in ranch then come and
take it
well I don't want to touch that stuff so
I won't do that but I actually I'm not
one of these people that has a problem
with pineapple pizza okay I will you
have my blessing you want to put
pineapple on your pizza that's fine I
don't I don't see Pizza as this sacred
thing you could you can try different
toppings I have a very surprisingly open
mind when it comes to pizza but Ranch
doesn't belong on anything it is uh
if there is anything
well I'll put it this way
if there's any food item
that would be improved by Ranch
then that is a food item that is not fit
for human consumption to begin with
so that's the way that I would slice it
so to speak
in 2022 we launched Jeremy's razors as a
joke at first but it was an important
joke now just nine months and 15 premium
products later we've amassed the largest
social media following of any brand in
the category and taken over 10 million
dollars away from so-called Men's
Grooming companies that despise
masculinity but that was just the
beginning this year we've got even more
great products and woke scorching
Endeavors in stores so skip the
resolutions and Join the Revolution
that was good I like that together we'll
we'll upend the woke onomy and finally
give conservatives a return on their
values are you ready to really make a
change this year we'll pick up Jeremy's
razors Hair Skin beard and body care
products today by going to dailywire.com
dailywire.com Walsh now let's get to our
daily cancellation
[Music]
after Buffalo Bills player Demar Hamlin
collapsed on the field everyone on
social media and in the news media and
especially in sports media agreed and
said out loud over and over and over
again that football is just a game and
that when stacked up against matters of
life and death
it is completely unimportant now this is
of course true and Incredibly obvious so
obvious in fact that it doesn't really
need to be said much less doesn't need
to be said 100 million times in a row
repeated over and over again like some
sort of incantation
but one thing we know about tragedies in
the modern world is that they serve as
occasions for people to issue totally
unnecessary statements just like that
not because they need to be said but
because the person making the statement
needs everyone else to see him making it
otherwise known as virtue signaling
and when it comes to pointless
unproductive games games that especially
should not be a top priority in the
light of tragic occurrences like the
Demar Hamlin incident this game the game
of virtue signaling is even more
pointless and less productive than
football
that's especially the case for the
particular brand of virtue signaling
that comes in the form of performative
outrage this obviously is the internet's
favorite kind of virtue signaling and
favorite game and ironically many of the
people who tripped over themselves to
clarify and declare that games aren't
important now that Demar Hamlin is in
the hospital we're in that very moment
at the same time playing the most
frivolous self-serving grotesque game of
all which is performative virtue
signaling outrage
now we know how the game is played
as soon as the terrible event occurs the
hordes of frivolous simpering idiots
immediately begin prowling the internet
in search of any opinions connected to
the event that they the frivolous
timbering idiots can label as somehow
inappropriate or out of bounds
then every single person in this group
will individually denounce the bad
opinion
so the bad thing happens
that all these people go on the internet
say let's find someone saying something
bad about this
and once they find it every person
individually has to take turns saying I
disagree with this
even after it's been denounced 50
million times
still idiots number of 50 million in one
and 50 million and two and so on must
make sure to register their disapproval
as well
I also think this is bad they say
not because there's any need for this
allegedly bad opinion to be condemned
even more after it's already been
condemned by half the planet but only
because once again they want everyone
else to see them condemning it this is
how the game is played and after the
Demar Hamlin injury a number of
candidates were selected as targets for
this dog pile of dummies principle among
them was Sports pundit Skip Bayless now
to be totally clear I have no affinity
for Skip Bayless I I don't enjoy his
work I don't watch his show I don't care
about his opinions but that doesn't mean
that I'm going to pretend that even his
most benign statements are unthinkably
monstrous and heinous
yeah that's what's hap that's exactly
what happened on Monday night in
response to one in a series of tweets
that Bayless posted about the Hamlin
situation this one tweet the one that
provoked the ire of Millions
earned over a hundred thousand okay one
hundred thousand outraged comments in a
day and over 100 million views on
Twitter
we know that now because Elon changes
you can see how many views a tweak is
this one got over a hundred million
that's a third of the country
he was trending
higher site this one tweet about Hamlin
was allegedly so offensive so out of
bounds so scandals such an unseemly
Abomination that I received this level
of attention there were many outrage
media headlines published about it
people called for Bayless to be fired
from his Fox Sports show many
professional athletes joined in to the
cancellation chorus saying he should be
fired
the Tweet which I'll read in a moment
was called sick and gross and disgusting
and disgraceful
it was so bad that Skip's co-host on his
fox show Shannon sharp refused to come
to work and host the show with him on
Tuesday
because he was so upset by this tweet
it was so bad that skip not only
apologized for the Tweet now follow
tweet but even began his show which he
was hosting by himself Yesterday by
apologizing for even hosting a show to
begin with
watch
Jen allow me to say up front
that I apologize for what we're going to
set out to do here today if it offends
anyone because we're we're going to try
to do the show
pretty much as we usually do the show
but
I'll admit up front
I'm still Shook Up by what happened last
night to Demar Hamlin
in fact I'm still wrecked
in fact I'm not sure I'm capable of
doing this show today
but after barely sleeping on it
I decided to give it a try
maybe I'll fail maybe we will fail but
we're going to try
so he says he's wrecked incapable of
doing the show he couldn't sleep
because of this really
is a terrible very sad thing but it
is that well this is all performance we
see that's all this is
that's all any of this is It's
performance the outrage against Skip
Bayless bayless's response to it it's
all performance
and as for the tweet that set this all
off here it is okay get ready for it
um he tweeted on Monday night shortly
after the injury first occurred he said
no doubt the NFL is considering
postponing the rest of this game but how
this late in the season a game of this
magnitude is crucial to the regular
season outcome which suddenly seems so
irrelevant
that's it
159 million views 100 000 outraged
comments calls for termination because
of that
what exactly is the problem
he asks a rhetorical question about how
the NFL will handle rescheduling the
game while in the same breath
acknowledging that the game is
insignificant insignificant compared to
the tragedy what precisely is so
horrifying about that
the faux outrage mob will respond that
you know Bayless shouldn't have been
thinking at all about the logistics of
rescheduling the game at a time like
that even if he acknowledged out loud
that it's not important
but that's nonsense
every single person
watching the game at home
was wondering about how they'd handle
postponing and rescheduling and
especially a week before the regular
season is supposed to end
every person watching the game had that
same thought it's a normal thing to
think about
not because this consideration is more
important than Demar Hamlin's life but
simply because it's one thought of many
that happens across a human being's
brain people are capable of holding more
than one thought in their head at the
same time
now I will confess to you right now that
as I was sitting with my wife in our
living room and and we we saw this and
we had the same question we very briefly
acknowledge that canceling the game at
this point in the season presents an
interesting Challenge and we wondered
how they would handle it
if you had been sitting in the living
room with us and you overheard this very
brief Exchange
you would not have shrieked out in
horror and cried you monsters how dare
you that's a disgraceful thing to
briefly consider at a time like this
you would not have done that
because that would be insane that would
be an insane reaction to such a benign
nothing of a of a comment
and that's because that's the sort of
histrionic display that people Reserve
solely for social media and nowhere else
in life
there are a great many statements a
person can make that would be considered
perfectly normal in any other context of
light life and yet be greeted with
screeches of outrage on social media
where mob Rule and performative anger
combine to create an environment where
you simply are not allowed to say normal
things
the whole thing is obscene
a phony outrage mob is obscene Skip
Bayless well he's obscene too for plenty
of other reasons but in this particular
case the obscene thing is the tiresome
internet charade the pageant of fake
anger wherein a person where wherein a
person cries how dare you think the same
thing that I was also thinking
and by the way I was thinking and I
maybe would have tweeted myself until I
saw that you tweeted it and how people
reacted to you so I won't tweet it
instead I'll pretend to be outraged by
that thing myself
this is the state of things on the
internet at all times every day no
matter what is happening in the world
but the Outreach theater really kicks
into high gear and people put it put in
their most mellow dramatic Oscar bait
type performances when there is some
kind of tragic event right as soon as
the tragedy occurs the mob begins laying
traps in the form of these arbitrary
rules
and depending on the tragedy there are
things you are allowed to say and things
you're not allowed to say
you're not going to know what the rules
are until you've run afoul of them
that's the game
part of the fun for the outrage mob is
that they change the rules for every
tragedy they move the landmines around
and they sit back barely disguising
their gleeful anticipation as they wait
for people to step on them
now of course
another aspect of the game here is that
not every tragic event in the world
registers on social media
people die every day terrible things
happen every day people die in the
course of doing their jobs every day and
most of these atrocities and tragedies
are ignored entirely you're allowed to
carry on with your life say whatever you
want without even acknowledging it
in fact there's a lot of death that
happens every single day that you're
allowed to make light of on Twitter I
mean there are literally videos posted
on Twitter of people dying like videos
of death posted on Twitter that people
will post and joke about
here's a video of someone actively dying
in front of you isn't this funny
well that's okay
every once in a while though one tragic
event is selected as the main topic of
conversation on social media and all of
the rules of conversation change in
light of it
everything you're allowed to say even if
it's not about the subject now changes
though again you're not you're not going
to know the rules until you violate them
and then in a day or two maybe two days
you know maybe three days it will be
randomly decided that enough time has
been spent on the tragedy and everybody
just moves on
and most of the people who are so
emotionally affected by this event will
never say another word about it ever
again for as long as they live
and they will carry on as if it never
happened
that's all part of the game
and the real terrible consequence is
that it turns the people who play this
game
into sociopaths
incapable of experiencing authentic
human emotion
you know those who grow so accustomed to
performing emotion performing it
performing emotion they eventually
forget how to actually feel emotion
so ironically as they appear
increasingly oversensitive
they're actually becoming the opposite
they aren't sensitive they're sociopaths
feigning outrage feigning sadness
because they cannot feel it
they can't feel anything else either
and that is why they
the faux outrage mob coming after Skip
Bayless though not Skip Bayless himself
are today canceled they'll Skip Bayless
will I'm sure get his turn
in due time and I'll do it for this
portion of the show as you move over to
the members block hope to see you there
if not talk to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
foreign
[Music]